from denying enslaved people full
citizenship
until the 13th 14th and 15th amendments
after the civil war
to nine women the right to vote until
the 19th amendment 100 years ago
to pull taxes and literacy tests and the
ku klux klan campaigns of violence and
terror
finally someone with the guts to call
out the klu klux klans
stupid racists of the sea
i bet they i bet they're democrats
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's tuesday everyone so look at these
happy people
these are texas democratic lawmakers as
they fled the state
like hunter biden running from a
pregnant stripper
they left yesterday to deny republicans
the quorum needed to vote on
strengthening election safeguards or as
the democrats like to call such
safeguards
the worst thing since the civil war
he'll also decry efforts to strip the
right to vote as authoritarian and
anti-american
and he will highlight the work of the
administration against this the
necessity of passing the for the people
act and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
and how we need to work together with
civil rights organizations
to build as broad a turnout and voter
education system to overcome
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war
the worst challenge to our democracy
since the civil war
hold on a second i was told just days
ago that the worst thing since the civil
war was january 6.
you guys got to get your worst thing
since the civil war story straight
you've been comparing it to anything you
don't like to the civil war
yes i'd like to return this shirt why
didn't it fit no it's the worst thing
since the civil war
but i guess it beats this callback he's
going to let the big banks once again
write their own rules
unchain wall street
they're going to put you all back in
chains
[Applause]
yep the race baiters still got it
so what's he calling voter id now
i'm convinced that we'll be able to stop
this because it is the most pernicious
thing
this makes jim crow look like jim eagle
this is gigantic
poor jim eagle there's some guy
in scranton going i had nothing to do
with this
that made no sense but this old white
guy loves jitting up division almost as
much as hunter loved crack
it's his crack oh
sorry he's a crack addict that's my
fault he's some unifier
but maybe it's time to freshen up the
analogies have you thought about
exploiting 911
like this mutant the 1-6 attack
for the future of the country's a
profoundly more dangerous event than the
911 attacks
and in the end the 1-6 attacks are
likely to kill a lot more americans
that were killed on the 911 attacks
which will include the casualties
of the wars that lasted 20 years
following it
so how did this psychopath get past
security
i was waiting for two hospital orderlies
dressed in white coats to throw a net
over him at the end
but the only way dumbass sleaze bags
like that get ahead is in the darkness
lack of transparency is the cloak for
malfeasance
so is it any wonder that the dems see
any effort at enhancing voting
transparency
as attack on them it almost makes you
think they might be hiding something
they did to win
the last election ah just kidding
let's state the obvious dems are trying
to block voter id not because it makes
it harder to vote but that it makes it
harder to illegally vote
it's that simple but this is why when
you ask dems
which voters that voter id might limit
they can never give a name so they just
tie ids to racism
even though it's obviously absurd you
need ids to drive a car
take out a library book get a fishing
license buy a gun
this is sounding a lot like joe mackey's
dream weekend
[Applause]
great jacket speed racer but also
you need an id to buy that light beer
that's sitting in that charter bus
yeah you need an id kids but really
light beer
seems a little late for that in the
afternoon
late in the afternoon so they spent
thousands on a private plane but cut
corners with a beer that has a lower
alcohol content than
cat's bloodstream the beer must be the
only thing they paid out of pocket right
we're on the taxpayers dime they'd be
splashing cristal like they just won the
stanley cup
but they look happy and masculist and
why not masks are for kids on 100 degree
playgrounds not dems and air
conditioning
this flea bargain has been done before
back in may when they ran away to
prevent republicans from voting on the
earlier bill
these dopes flee more than the felons
their party bailed out after the riots
in fact here's the only occupation where
not doing it
is considered part of the job it's like
being a fact checker for cnn
or a hairstyle or a hair stylist for a
brian stelter
doesn't matter none of this does here's
why in the repo
if the republicans came out for hugs the
dems would be anti-hug
but if the gop were anti-hug the dems
would come at you like kevin spacey at a
boy scout sleepover
i don't even know what that means i do
okay
the entire democrat platform is based on
staking out positions defined
by their hatred for red states and red
hats
and it's forced them to take more absurd
positions than gumby
studying the kama sutra remember the
defund police
the defund police movement occurred
because trump was pro-law enforcement
and look at anything the republicans are
naturally for school choice law
order american interest in general and
you'll find a rabble of democrats
forming a spiteful opposition it's like
a chess game
where your opponent is a robot that
punches you in the face after each one
of your moves
so why are you playing it all it's not
politics it's
pointed antagonism that then becomes
cemented as real
so they really start believing socialism
is preferable to capitalism
that ids are impossible to get therefore
racist that cops aren't necessary that
we need to teach kids that white folks
are inherently racist
while they buy fancy homes send their
kids to private schools hire security
guards
and dine in expensive restaurants
without masks or shame
all these nonsense ideas sprout from one
reflex
to not be associated with the likes of
you
the democrats are now just a i hate you
party
they don't feel that way about actual
american adversaries because you can
only hate one group
all the time and that's you i wonder
what the angry white male thinks
[Music]
yeah when i was growing up everyone was
always talking about peace and love
nowadays people who claim to believe
those things just want to demonize
people
it's as if they take pleasure in it yeah
somebody ought to write a book call it
uh i don't know the joy of hate
as if that would ever happen
[Applause]
you could still order it on amazon joy
of hate it's my first book
not really first new york times
bestseller but why count
what does the angry black male think
about how bad voter id is
[Music]
bruh this is my lunch time
white chocolate cranberry
man this is oh
this is worse than the potato famine
no this is worse than the island where
the trees got all cut down and
everybody had to become cannibals oh my
god this is
no it's not not even close
not even a little bit
it's not
not
now imagine if the republicans acted
like democrats and rejected any idea
associated with their opposition party
maybe that's the way forward problem is
the dems don't have any ideas except
to hate your ideas without us to hate
they got
nothing no ideas no solutions no decent
beer
we can't even debate them because we're
just debating a child screaming
i despise you as they side with
criminals and authoritarians and
neo-racists
so i hope they enjoy their flight to dc
on their private plane
but when they return to texas let's hope
someone changed the locks
she kept jim acosta on his toes by
lifting him up by his throats
outnumbered co-host haley mcinius
comedy club crowds flocked to him to get
their parking validated
comedian joe mackey
speed freaks ask her to take it down a
notch fox news contributor
cat tim and he's banned
from entering low tunnels my massive
sidekick and joseph that said
fox station paris
[Applause]
[Music]
kayleigh it seems like every time
there's a republican or an issue
it's the worst thing ever so it's like
they have this
the media and the democrats have this
weird amnesia they forget that like
just months ago something was worse than
what was worse than watergate
now it's worse than the civil war now
it's worse than 9 11. they're running
out of things to be worse than
well joe certainly does seem like he has
amnesia so that's a start
yes um but yeah one thing is worse than
the other then they move to the next and
what is
baffling to me you know the liberal fact
checkers they never quote
fact check the liberals yeah and when
they do we should pay extra scrutiny to
that because you have the washington
post who gives joe biden four pinocchios
for saying that george's voting laws jim
crow on steroids so he says
instead of back peddling okay it's not
jim crow it's worse than the civil war
yeah how is that logical yeah and
where's the cnn fact checkers apparently
daniel dale has a fact checked
in the entire month of july come on now
yes you know what daniel dale missing
in his fact-checking might be worse than
watergate
that is true i'm pulling a carl
bernstein here but
that would be we should do that we
should do fact checking of all of the
like
no it is our fact checkers no joe this
is not worse than the civil war
here's why a half a million people died
killing each other over slavery
prided but prized by the democrats
so joe you weren't around for the civil
war
that's that's true but you could argue
that the civil war was
was good right yes because i mean it
ended slavery
that's true so it's kind of a trick
question you're trying to
trying to trap me uh it's true
if everything's worse than the civil war
if everything is worse than the civil
war by your perspective
well slavery was bad so we had to have
the civil war and that's unfortunate but
yes
you're sure about that joe you didn't
seem very confident
i'm watching ty tyrus i have not waffled
i have been pro-north and anti-slavery
my entire life
damn straight all right i was actually
asked that does donald trump wish the
south had won the civil war
reporter actually asked me that question
so thanks for clarifying where you stand
well i also think that the democrats are
as bad at coming up with comparisons as
they are at phony obstacles for why you
can't vote
because one day it's you can't go
photocopy something if you live in
arkansas and the next day
it's as bad as the civil war uh and i'd
also like to address that the jacket
issue um i got a lot of heat from my
last jacket and i think this one looks
pretty
cool
what is the uh what's the brand of what
is the brand you know
i don't know
again i'm not sure if it's
merry-go-round or the chess king
but uh i don't know tyrus what do you
think of his jacket
i think it goes good with like a
motorcycle with like gloves
and a taller dude but other than that
it's phenomenal i love joe yeah um
you're a monologue man you got some
zingers today wow uh
i'm kind of it makes a lot of sense to
me about the racist clam thing
it explains a lot of the things i'm
hearing at the beach like i'm trying to
swim with my kids and like dark you get
off the who is that's the clamp
and all this time it was a clamp yes we
need to get like a muppet or something
made of like a racist clam and have a
little segment where he comes on
oh you know who clicks clam yes why not
yes
and i thought it was awesome that he
told someone they should be put back in
chains and everyone was like
[Music]
it's cool because it came from him yeah
that's the one the time when
someone will come for and be like well
he really doesn't know what he's saying
so just give him a break
because he's getting more angry old
white dude as this thing goes on
so we're going to start seeing some
really cool coming out of
president biden's mouth that we're going
to be like
that was racist yeah but he was talking
to
uh uh that was a couple of years ago
well uh talking to a predominantly black
audience and they he was telling them
that if they elect
elected mitt romney right was that what
it was about i think that they would
go back into chains change look at the
little nervous white guy trying to clean
up for the other white guy
i don't give a damn who he was talking
to but this is how nervous white america
is
he's terrified joe biden said you'd be
back and change because like i just want
you to know that the only reason why i
played that is because the audience
was i was not there i did not condone it
i swear to god relax no i'm trying to
relax it's worse
no relax you guys are paranoid like his
jacket's fully zipped up he's
uncomfortable
he's trying to conceal his whiteness by
off brown colors
he can't and you're trying to pass the
buck to other old white guys this is
i'm living in sarcastic brother hammond
please continue comfortably all right
how are you doing there cat i'm all
right yes how's the steroids i'm on
steroids so
uh i actually i have a whole thank you i
have a horrible sinus issue that i
have surgery in a few weeks and the
steroids i don't feel any
better i still feel terrible but now
that i'm on steroids i'm like i feel
terrible but so much like
you've been like you've been through
work get over it
like that's how i feel and it's kind of
nice it's kind of exciting it's kind of
like
yeah i'm not why don't you start doing
this i'm saying do
five sets of curls every morning and i
want to see giant muscles
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna start at least
doing four sit-ups a day
i'm gonna do four side-ups a day i
should have a six-pack in time for
surgery you want to have a six-pack for
surgery
don't you yes yeah i totally bike riders
like this
uh i get why i could ride a bike did you
ask me a question
you know what we're out of time
9 11 was bad sign 9 11 was 9 11 was bad
it was as bad as the civil war yes and
so with you
so was slavery exactly all right i'm
glad we got our priorities
in order hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else